Welcome back everyone this is my moon knight gorr
the god butcher deleted scene video also talk about
a deleted scene with kang that they just talked
about in the moonlight series that's right they
actually legit had kang and gorr the god butcher
in moon knight there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs and connections to the upcoming marvel movies
obviously so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos real quick shout out to
my friends at noon who asked to sponsor this
video a lot of you always ask how i have so much
energy to make videos non-stop 24 7. it's a rough
schedule i was an ncaa swimmer back in college so
i still try to stay as healthy as possible now
in exercise as much as possible but it is crazy
to keep up with everything it's like this all the
time so i need all the help i can get nume is a
consumer-led digital platform they're experts
in physical change nume leverages a powerful
combination of human coaches psychology science to
empower people to take control of their own health
they aim to aid you with the wisdom and guidance
you need to practice making more thoughtful
choices every day in order to make a sustainable
change one of my favorite things about noom is the
daily lessons so every day you boot up the program
and there's this new curriculum for you to learn
one of them is for their food coloring system they
have this coloring system from green to yellow to
red green means it has more water in it it's meant
to be more healthy which means you stay fuller for
longer even just using new for a little while
on a daily basis helped me find a healthier
diet and it really helped my workout routine but
noon customizes for every person's needs so when
you start using the service they give you a full
evaluation asking all kinds of great questions
about your current lifestyle and what specifically
you want to achieve they will make a fully
customized program run by real coaches and backed
by science based on how you answer the questions
in the initial evaluation noom is like having
a personal trainer in your pocket you can visit
noom.com emergencyawesome to get a free evaluation
today and they'll build out a whole custom program
that will help you reach your goals so be sure to
check it out i'll put a link in the description
for that too but during the last episode of moon
knight the director revealed that they actually
wrote and filmed scenes that included both king
the conqueror and gorr the god butcher in order
to link up moon knight with the other upcoming
marvel movies like thor love and thunder ant-man
3 quantomania and then obviously loki season 2
because that deals a lot with kang the conqueror
both of them were doing completely different
things obviously they're on different missions
inside the mcu that have very different paths
during episode six the finale when arthur harrow
has shot moon knight he's dead stuck inside
the minespace hospital version of the afterlife
arthur herro takes ahmed's stone prison and
heads back to the great pyramid in her mere
presence like even though he hasn't freed her
yet her mere presence in his hand enhances his
strength so that he can area of affect everyone
but when that happens that sort of sets off all
the warning bells inside the other gods heads
they start to figure out what's going on slowly
without completely figuring everything out even
though it's the avatars that come rushing into
the great pyramid yelling about this like what's
happening why is everything going crazy again
they're meant to know everything that their
egyptian gods know that they are the avatars
up so they're basically saying all the things that
the gods are thinking they don't immediately know
that it's omit that's causing these problems it's
half horror that has to tell them no no this is
happening because of ahmed the deleted scene with
gorr of the god butcher was going to be happening
during this part of the movie as omit gets ready
to be freed the other avatars the gods were going
to come running into the great pyramid yelling
about chaos erupting everywhere what's going on
now all of a sudden and as part of that they were
going to start yelling about gor the god butcher
specifically like first we had all this stuff with
gorr the god butcher going around trying to kill
all of us that was a huge problem and now we have
this thing with amit going on when does it end and
it was meant to explain why the other gods had not
intervened with what arthur harrow and amit were
doing until it was too late because they would
have been busy trying to stop gorr the godbutcher
who'd been tearing through their pantheon up to
this point we talked about this a little bit after
episode three during episode three when khonshu
takes over marc spector's body and he has this
tribunal with the other gods that are part of
the anya pantheon they say that two of the gods
who were part of that pantheon the ruling council
had gone missing recently and the other gods had
no idea what had happened to them like how do
you lose track of a couple gods if you yourself
are a god and have this crazy level of power the
show runners basically confirm what we all thought
at the time the reason that the gods started to go
missing was because gorr was going around killing
all of them with his version of the necro sword
in the mcu and they just gotten frightened in a
way that they had never known real fear in eons
because as gods they had a lot of hubris they
had incredible power so they just thought that
they were untouchable in this pocket dimension
that they've been hiding out in when they were
teasing the great rift the whole idea that the mcu
gods that are part of this enid pantheon had left
humanity they basically transferred their souls in
the way that you saw during the episode with marc
spector transferring to the afterlife transferring
to another dimension called the other void which
is kind of like a pocket dimension that's why they
weren't able to directly intervene in a lot of
things that were physically happening in the mcu
like they had limited ability to interact with the
physical mcu and they had to use their avatars if
they wanted to do things conscious for example
had to use marc spector or steven grant or now
jake lockley when he actually wanted to really do
big stuff inside the mcu amit for example though
was physically inside the mcu that's why she was
so much more powerful at first than khonshu the
idea being that the more souls she consumed the
more powerful she'd become the more unstoppable
she'd become somebody call gorr the god butcher
get him here even faster the funny thing about
that is even though she wasn't at the top of gorge
list she would have been on it for sure eventually
the gorr going after khonshu's pantheon kind
of lines up with what his comic book story was
in the events leading up to the mcu version of
thor love and thunder they're changing some of
the gorr story line from the comics but it'll
feel very similar to the comic book storyline
when that movie picks up gorbal have already been
on his mission to kill the gods for a while around
the rest of the universe the events of the movie
take place when he finally comes for new asgard
on earth and thor but thor was only part of his
mission he didn't start out killing all the gods
because of anything specific that thor himself
had done in the past it was because of what his
own peoples gods a completely different pantheon
had done there been a lot of recent tragedies in
the mcu like the mcu's seen a lot of city miles
one bad thing after another just here we go again
first thanos wipes out half the universe with a
snap avengers infinity war then even though the
hulk brought everyone back with iron man's nano
infinity gauntlet spider-man and doctor strange
then almost broke the multiverse with their
spell even though they put some flex tape on it
then scarlet witch doctor strange and now the
king variants with the king multiverse war are
breaking the multiverse in a permanent kind of way
leading to the time runs out scenario secret wars
situation with all the incursions but while
that's going down on a smaller level you
have gorr's family dying in a very senseless very
preventable everyday kind of death and it kind of
drives him mad when he learns that the gods of his
people like his own pantheon completely different
part of the universe could have prevented it from
happening and just chose not to like the gods of
his people like a lot of gods around the mcu don't
really care that much about their people you kind
of see that with khonshu. Khonshu is meant to be
an example of the really terrible kind of god like
yes you're kind of doing good things but you're
also really really terrible go back to sleep worm
uh the idiot's in control segura decides that the
gods are useless do not deserve to exist and then
finds the necro sword giving him the power to kill
gods and starts by killing the gods of his people
then goes on a quest to kill the gods around
the rest of the mcu universe and he does it old
school thanos style balancing the universe
perfectly balanced as all things should be
one pantheon at a time but as gorr kills
more and more pantheons of gods he gains
more and more power and eventually even though
conscious pantheon for example is hiding out in
this pocket dimension in a completely different
part outside the mcu they'd be safe from thanos
snapping the infinity gauntlet or anything
on that level because that only affects stuff
inside the mcu eventually gorr would gain enough
power that he could travel through the multiverse
and those other gods would not be safe so even
though the kang multiverse war the incursions from
doctor strange two universes colliding with each
other is now threatening all of reality gorr the
god butcher himself is also kind of threatening
all of reality in a completely different way but
one of the reasons why they've been trying to hype
up gorr the god picture in general is saying that
he's one of the better marvel villains is because
you understand why he's doing what he's doing
because you saw moon knight you saw how terrible
khonshu is how terrible the other gods are
so gorr is not wrong in thinking that most of
the gods are really capricious don't care about
their people and don't really deserve to exist the
whole twist of moonite is they wanted to show you
that kanchi was just as bad as ahmed even though
what she was doing seemed like it was way worse
going full minority report on the entire mcu she
was very upfront and open about her plan khonshu
used a lot of deception a lot of trickery to trick
marc spector into a contract by using jake lockley
completely different personality to keep them
under his thumb all the bad things that arthur
harrow said about khonshu during their trial were
meant to be true about him dominating his avatars
abusing them abusing him when he was khonshu's
avatar all 100 percent true in the whole thing
with the kang the conqueror deleted scene because
obviously the kang multiverse war has something to
do with what's going on with the incursions and
doctor strange too is that in earlier episodes
when stephen was rattling off about egyptian
history and a bunch of ancient pharaohs he would
have specifically mentioned rama tut as part of
this line of pharaohs and that would have been a
reference to king the conqueror when he went back
to ancient egypt to rule over them way before he
adopted the name king the conqueror i've already
done a longer video about this so i'll post links
in the description below it was just that during
the episodes there are easter eggs about king
but the deleted scene was that they were legit
going to start talking about king the conqueror
there was also a symbol on a jacket in a previous
episode that looks similar to kang's egyptian
headpiece so there was a lot of kang going on
during the series i've got more videos planned
for fantastic four for the incursions secret wars
time runs out make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss those but if you
have any questions about what's going on with gord
of the goblins or any of these other brand new
characters just write them in the comments below
congratulations reality you're the
giveaway winner for my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my doctor strange 2 iron
man deleted scene video to learn what was going on
with him during the movie and click here for
my doctor strange 2 post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!